Something terrible happened here.
And for decades, people didn’t talk about
it.
“I was an adult before I ever heard about
It was something that was hidden.”
“This entire historic community was obliterated.”
“Bodies dumped in rivers bodies dumped in
mass graves.
It was an absolute massacre.”
This story isn’t one you’ll find in most
history books.
And almost 100 years later, the facts of what
exactly happened that day...are still unraveling.
“So we’re driving in what’s known as
Black Wall Street.
It’s where one of the nation’s worst episodes
of racial violence took place.”
In 1921 — a neighborhood in Tulsa, Oklahoma
called the Greenwood District, was a bustling
community of black-owned businesses.
Tulsa locals know that period of Greenwood’s
history as a kind of Golden Age.
“If you can imagine just like an old time
downtown, things like movie theaters, pharmacy's,
hair salons, and so forth.”
They called it, “Black Wall Street”.
“It was a mecca, it was a huge success.”
But Black Wall Street was also an anomaly.
It thrived at a time when the KKK was incredibly
active in Oklahoma and the nation had just
been through the “Red Summer of 1919”
— when white mobs murdered black people
in dozens of incidents across the US.
“There needed to be a sort of match or an
igniter tossed on these embers and that event
was, that trigger event, was an incident that
involved two teenagers: Dick Rowland, 19-year-old
black boy who shined shoes downtown.
Sarah Page, 17-year-old white girl who ran
an elevator in a downtown building called
the Drexel Building.
He went to the building boarded the elevator.
Something happened.
Sarah Page began to scream.
They both ran out of the elevator.”
Now we don’t know exactly what happened
in this elevator — but a day later, Rowland
was arrested and taken to the courthouse.
The local newspaper ran an article claiming
Rowland had assaulted Page.
Even though Page refused to press charges, the
article was essentially a call to action
for whites.
“A large white mob began to gather on the
lawn of the courthouse.
Dick Rowland was in jail on the top floor.
A number of black men, several dozen, marched
down to the courthouse to protect him.
Some of them armed.
There was a struggle between one of the black
men in the small group and one of the white
men in a larger group.
And things sort of went south from from that
point.”
Hundreds of white people descended upon Black
Wall Street, armed.
Black residents withdrew behind the railroad
tracks that marked off the Greenwood district.
Some of them were armed, and fought back.
But they were outnumbered by the white mob, which
shot their way through.
The white mob murdered.
They looted.
And they set fire to Black Wall Street.
“This was the strategy, if you will, of
how to deal with these successful black communities.
The effects were disastrous.”
For two days, the Greenwood district burned.
Martial law was declared.
And the National Guard was brought in.
By the time the massacre ended, Greenwood
was in ruins.
More than 1200 homes were destroyed, and 35
blocks, burned.
The exact number of casualties is harder to
pin down.
Some initially only reported that white people
died.
Others, reported somewhere between 30 and
100 mostly black casualties.
But estimates now put that number closer to
300.
As for those that survived, thousands of them
lived in tents cities in the months that followed...and
were left to pick up the pieces of rubble
they once called home.
After the massacre, the cover up started.
Records went missing from city files — including
the very article that started it all.
It makes photos from this time all the more
important as part of the historical record.
But back in 1921, these images served a very
different purpose.
“So photo postcards like these were widely
distributed after the massacre.
At the time they were a part of white supremacist
culture, and kept as souvenirs of racially
charged crimes.”
Now, they’re preserved to make sure this
part of Tulsa’s history isn’t forgotten
— and they paint a clear picture of how
much destruction there was that day.
On the postcards, it’s called “The Tulsa
Race Riot” — a name that, itself, sort
of erases what really happened.
“By calling it a riot, it's a way of trying
to rewrite the history, assuming that there
were both sides at fault and that was not
the case.
I call it a massacre and I call it that, because that’s what
it was.”
Greenwood eventually rebuilt.
But nearly a century later, there’s a part
of this story that still haunts the city.
No one actually knows where the victims’
bodies are.
“We’ve got to find our people we've got
to put them at rest.
If not we continue to be haunted by what was
done so many years ago.”
Kavin Ross, a local writer, is one of many
in Tulsa, descended from people who lost everything
in the massacre.
“So in this cemetery there are only two
official victims of the Tulsa race massacre.
How many victims do you think there are?”
“After all these years, I think 300 is putting
it mild.”
In 1997, the city finally put together a commission
to study the massacre, and help piece together
what happened in 1921.
They compiled records, and eyewitness accounts.
“The bullets were just raining down over
us.”
“They set our house on fire and went right
straight to the curtains and set the curtains
on fire.”
These accounts are especially important now
— because none of these survivors are alive
anymore.
And they also provided new information.
Some mentioned trucks - like this one - loaded
with victims of the riot.
One riot witness in particular came forth, testifying that he saw
bodies being dumped in Oaklawn Cemetery.
“This is it.
This is the area.”
Using the survivor accounts, records, and
eventually, radar — the city was able
to pinpoint three locations with anomalies
in the soil.
Only one step was left, to excavate.
But it was something the city, at the time,
wasn’t up for doing.
For many Tulsans, it was a part of history
best forgotten, and not worth investigating.
In some ways, today, that sentiment remains.
“Kind of a waste of money." "Why do you think that?" "It’s over. It's done with."
But there are clear signs of a city that’s
ready to come to terms with a dark chapter
in its history.
“Honestly that’s a lot of missing people,
people that probably had families.”
“We owe it to the people who whose blood
has actually fertilized the grounds of this
place.”
“There was a tremendous amount of racism”
“Injustice plus time does not equal justice.”
Today, a new mayor is re-opening the investigation.
“I think a pretty basic compact that a city
makes with its citizens is, if somebody murders
you we will do everything we can to find out
what happened to you and give your family
closure.
Whether you were murdered yesterday or you
were murdered 98 years ago.”
The city will be looking into the three areas
that the commission noted.
That process — of finding out what lies
beneath Tulsa — and DNA matching any remains
with descendants, could take years.
The investigation is just one part of a bigger
historical reckoning.
But the reality is, it can't undo the crimes or the cover up
of the 1921 Tulsa Race Massacre.
“This story is the greatest conspiracy of
silence that I've ever seen in history.”
“Thanks for watching.
If you haven’t already heard, we’ve launched
a paid membership program called the Video Lab
For a monthly fee, subscribers get access
to tons of special features.
Becoming a member is the best way to support
our work, so head on over to Vox.com/join to
sign up.
See you there.”